there has been this spike in acute
flaccid myelitis what do we know about
where it comes from and where do you
think this is headed
well it's a very serious condition it's
a very rare condition about one in a
million we first recognized it in 2014
when there was an increase incidence of
acute flaccid myelitis about 120 cases
that year and then a lull in 2016 about
149 and then a law and then this year we
have about a hundred and fifty-five
suspected cases of which 62 have been
confirmed CDC has been working very hard
on this since 2014 to try to understand
causation etiology as we sit here today
we don't have understanding of the cause
we are you know continuing to strengthen
our efforts working in partnership with
state and territorial health departments
and academic experts to try to figure
this out and I recently asked again to
put together a task force to really try
to look at where we're at and what else
could we do to try to solve this problem
the good news is that it doesn't appear
to be transmissible from human to human
we don't see clustering in families
I want to make it clear to the American
public it's not polio all right we're
confident of that I do think that this
is a new occurrence in the United States
the AFM our our suspicion is it's caused
by a single agent that's the dominant
disease that we're confronting right now
I was saying the other day to my
colleagues you know when the AIDS
epidemic started CDC formed the task
force and was able to figure out
etiology in three years
in retrospect that's remarkable the way
you do that is you form a very strict
case definition it's not that you want
to include everybody that might have it
you want to be certain that everybody
you include has what you're looking for
of course that's why there's some
discrepancy sometimes with CDC when we
say these are the cases we've confirmed
and maybe
the states may report others that are
suspected we're trying to get a very
solid group of individuals that were
confident had this new mysterious
syndrome that we can then use to try to
understand etiology